(majestic music)
- Zombies.
They're hot right now.
Oh, yeah.
The Walking Dead,
the Talking Dead,
Fear the Walking Dead,
Be the Walking Dead.
Walking Dead Top Chef,
Walking Dead Real World,
World War Z, it's
prequel, World War Y,
it's sequel World War A.
Zombies are everywhere.
That's where Rutger
St. Lawrence comes in.
See, Rutger is a pure
warrior of the mind.
Tortured eyes radiate compassion
whilst wisdom dances
from his every man lips.
He has seen and said it all.
Most people in this new world
have had to become handy
with a weapon to
survive, but not Rutger.
Oh, no, he was
born with a weapon.
His words.
(paper crackles)
And when I see
whoever it may be,
a he or a she but
probably a she,
then I will be the one
that pollinates thee,
like the bees does the tree
and then finally
you and I will see
the word that needs no rhyme.
Love.
(book slamming)
And with every zombies'
mind he blows to pieces,
he brings back another
piece of humanity
in the hopes of world peace.
Also, he's a black guy.
(dramatic music)
- We're very excited about this
and we'll call you when
we're ready to make an offer.
(slamming on table)
- You keep that.
I got plenty.